dustin is in dunkirk maryland hi dustin
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you anthony how are you
guys better than we deserve sir how can
we help
hey i'm a first newsletter so if my
words of mumble just
let me push through um i
currently um owe twenty thousand dollars
on
a uh my last loan and i'll be debt free
carmax today offered me twenty six
thousand dollars
i love my truck but i want to be
debt-free more um
my parents and my friends are like keep
the truck don't worry about the debt
but i want to call you guys and get your
opinion
wow how old are you i'm
37 sir what's your household income
uh 117 000
okay and your only debt is 20 thousand
dollars on this truck
yeah yes sir and you love it and you
love the truck
yes but i want to be debt free oh i want
you to be debt free so i disagree with
your family or whoever it is that says
don't worry about the debt anthony we
worry about today absolutely i i do
worry about the debt
but you got a great income and you love
this truck won't you reach over and
knock it out in the next few months
yeah absolutely because here's my fear
you'll sell the truck go buy you a car
for six thousand dollars and you won't
be happy and and i think
and you'll buy another truck in two
years exactly you know so if you have
the money
twenty thousand dollars with 117 k
grosses mean you're bringing in about 85
as a single person right you can have
this thing paid off
yeah minimum uh every two weeks uh but
i guess my thing is right now i am i'm
home in maryland so that's why i gave
dunkirk but i live in new york
okay but how fast how fast can you pay
it off yeah
um because i'm a lot of work i cannot
get a side uh
a side job you don't need it
i could pay it off by the end of the
year
yeah yeah that's what i was thinking i
mean 10 months
yeah that's 2 000 bucks a month you
ought to be able to do that you probably
will actually do it a little bit faster
because you hate debt
yeah yes yeah i mean you'll probably go
on beans and rice a little deeper it
sounds like you're single
yes okay which means you don't have to
talk anybody into this
you just go on beans and rice you can
just say i now have
no life until the truck is paid because
i love this truck enough i'm going to
give up
lifestyle for eight to ten months
to be able to keep it and knock it out
and next time we get ready to do
something like this we'll just save up
and pay for it because you're committed
to no debt right yeah
uh uh yes sir so so you're saying
i would keep it if i since you like it
yes
yeah i drove my raptor this morning i
like it enough
to give up 10 months of lifestyle to get
to keep it
yeah and and lifestyle destin i'm a
challenge dave on 2000. i'ma stretch it
at three thousand dollars a month
you know because i think that hearing as
a single person
the only expensive thing you should have
is your rent and so everything else bro
you're eating at home
you're not going out on dating yeah
anthony i'm
i'm cashflow in college oh
that's 1840 every two months but i get
reimbursed
not my agency so it's i retract that
sorry there's an added piece of
mathematics yeah
okay i'm with you yeah so hey man i'm
proud of you you're doing good stuff
if you if you want to sell your truck
you can yeah but i think within 24
months you'll be back into a truck
very similar to that that you pay cash
for and i wouldn't go through all that
gyration to end up in the same place
three years from now yeah i agree
and so far i've paid all 60 grand since
october 2019
and i just already backed my psp because
it's been almost two years
you started back your tsp yes sir
because it's been almost two
to two years and and you said uh
if you can't pay your debt off within
two years start it back up
okay two no two to three years two to
three years if you're gonna do this i'd
stop the tsp for eight more months but
yeah i mean it's not you're fine you're
going to be all right because here's the
thing about you
you've got two or three things that are
going on one is uh you're teachable
two is you've decided to not borrow the
money anymore and
three is you're being very intentional
and thoughtful about every move with
money
yes you're not um you know you're not
wandering around there's not a bunch of
chaos in your life you're not making
this up as you go you're not being
impulsive
you're being very intentional
intentionality i mean when we do stupid
stuff all of us
is when we're just not paying attention
yes absolutely but when you are saying i
have a goal and
is this congruent with my goal no then
i'm not doing it
when you have that boundary in your life
that's not aligned to your goal
and not aligned to where i want to be
when i grow up so to speak then
that gives you the ability to go kill it
yeah and absolutely dave and here's the
thing i want people to hear dave and i
are not saying yes we like car payments
what we're saying is there's two things
one is less than 50
of his income and he can pay it off
within the next two years
and so because of those two things there
it's like okay you can you can keep it
if you want to
but if he wanted to sell it he could but
he likes a car and he'll be right back
there in two years
yeah it's not it's not going to be a uh
if this was going to be a seven year
thing or something and this knocked off
half of it yeah i would do it
but it's you've got everything done and
i would i would temporarily stop your
tsp again i'd tighten that budget as
tight as you can do it
and that eight to ten month mark by the
end of the year that's where i would be
with this so
well done sir yeah very well done hey
let's talk about it though he's cash
flow in college
that's neat i mean i was like don't drop
by that yeah don't let's not miss that
one america
he's not making any excuses he is being
intentional
he doesn't rack up any more debt he's
ready to get out of debt
i love that man keep that going you know
there's something to that
i mean it's um
it sounds kind of mean and i guess it is
but
the amount of whining that is going on
in our culture
the wussification of america the amount
of whining that people are making
excuses yes
and blaming some other outside force
for their inability to get up off their
assumptions and go do something correct
is astronomical it's unprecedented
the level of whining are there real
barriers
yeah i betcha absolutely you betcha yes
yeah
and uh you know are are there real
things that are out there
yeah are they keeping you from winning
not nearly as much as your belief that
you can't win
no you know what dave i say this the
greatest enemy to our success is our
excuse yeah that's it it's not it's not
the government it's not
uh the things out there are there real
issues out there that could prevent some
moving forward absolutely but the
greatest enemy to anthony o'neill
succeeding
is myself and my excuses yeah because i
take
one little possible excuse and i i give
it the weight of a thousand pounds
and it was a two pound weight right
right okay so
shut up yeah you know i mean that's what
i have to tell my little drama queen
self
you know shut up stop your freaking
whining
roll up your sleeves get up like he's
doing yeah
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home you know this is
up to you your destiny is more in your
control
than it is in control of the democrats
or the republicans
or whatever thing you want to watch on
the stupid news
turn off the news shut up and go make
you a life
i mean that is really the formula and
that's what this guy's doing and that's
how i know he's going to win we call it
intentionality but that's what it is
he's just not going to accept anything
except winning